a major breakthrough with North Korea
after a historic meeting inside the Oval
Office President Trump is now saying
he'll sit down with Kim jong-un in
Singapore we'll be meeting on June 12th
in Singapore I think it'll be a process
it's not I never said it goes in one
meeting I think it's going to be a
process but the relationships are
building and that's a great positive
things we talked about ending the war
and you know this war has been going on
it's got to be the longest war almost 70
years can you believe that we're talking
about the ending of the clearway the
president's announcement coming after
talking with North Korean vice chairman
kim yeongcheol at the White House for
over an hour president Trump also
surprising someone asked about receiving
a letter from kim jeong-hoon I haven't
seen the letter yet I purposely didn't
open the letter I haven't opened it I
didn't open it in front of the director
I said would you want me to open it he
said you can read it later I may be in
for a big surprise folks the president
has since read the letter I don't know
if he was in for a big surprise but that
happened all during the daily briefing
and that was my favorite part when he
made that little joke an amazing day I
think that the big news out of it
Kimberly is that yes of course the
summit is as a go at least today we'll
see how that goes for next week but also
the South Koreans have been pushing for
this possibility of signing an end to
the Korean War and the president
indicating that that is likely to be an
outcome of that first meeting it's not
necessarily the full denuclearization
all the civets stuff that he wants but
that is actually one of the go twos for
the South Koreans probably the North
Koreans as well yeah I think this is
really so historic in terms of what has
been accomplished so far no other
presidency has been able to get the ball
so far down and the court to be able to
do something like this in terms of
brokering some kind of peace agreement
denuclearization and when you saw this
today it got back on track in terms of
saying okay we're gonna be able to do
this summit this is something that
everybody should be very excited about
internationally because it brings the
chance and the opportunity for peace
instead
in a region that has been so
geopolitically fraught with danger with
a danger you know regime and what we see
here is he's really been able to bring
kim jeong-hoon
to the table and to his knees
essentially because he's his economy is
having its on the brink of collapse he
has really no choice but to come to the
table what President Trump has done with
tariffs what he's done with putting
pressure applying pressure with Chinese
what he's done in terms of his outreach
in relationship with South Korea as well
has all put this into motion in
relatively quick period of time early in
his presidency so I think it's most
auspicious and favorable for the United
States and for North and South Korea I
think event sanctions right now tariffs
because the President did say Jesse that
he had over a hundred additional
sanctions that he was ready to put on
and the North Koreans knew about that
and that in the meeting the president
said okay I won't do it at least not at
this moment if he doesn't like what he
sees when he opens the letter slap a few
more sanctions back on I was in my
fuchsia and downstairs earlier today and
they have to have the MSNBC channel on
because it's right under Rock Center so
I was forced to watch them cover this
hole you don't have Pepsi blame to us we
will judge you we won't judge you okay I
thought I needed to make that clear it's
not watching it on purpose
so and you know he's talking about
bringing like Kimberly said these two
sides together and ending a war that's
going on I mean we're still at war
technically it's been going on for
decades and the anchors come out and
they just criticize him for so they're
going back and forth on the Singapore
summit for canceling it and then going
back on and then saying what a hypocrite
he gets out of the Iran deal and then he
wants to make a deal with North Korea
and I'm thinking to myself you know if
this was President Obama okay and this
was going along the way it's going along
under presidents from being hailed the
guy that was in the White House today it
was it's amazing that they would bring a
guy who's responsible for hacking Sony
hacking on people's limbs doing some of
the most atrocious things to human
beings I think in the world he's one of
the most brutal people around into the
White House into the Oval Office and not
just for handing off a letter for them
just to sit and discuss things
the fact that you are forced to deal
with savage people in this world says a
lot about our country and what we're
willing to do in order to achieve peace
China is as you've been saying is pretty
integral in this they don't necessarily
want to see North Korea defanged they're
worried about a crisis with migrants
flowing across and let's just say Korea
comes together as one eventually a
powerhouse and then you have Japan right
there and our look their alliance with
the United States you have a pretty bold
kind of Western oriented alliance right
on China's doorstep they might not like
that too not too much so I guess we'll
just continue to see how China the
president said again Gregg my favorite
line and we'll see what happens yes but
he was a little bit more emphatic today
in talking about that this meeting will
not be the only meeting that it's not
going to be where you finish the whole
deal the other thing is he did I don't
know if we have the video if you guys
can pull it up oh he pulled that he not
only did he have an hour-long meeting
but he did like this personal diplomacy
and he actually walked them out to their
cars which was a huge sign of respect
and he took that not that like sort of
group picture that they could be showing
back in North Korea
well did two points one he kept saying
again and again that it's a process this
is always a process and you have to
remember this is a developer from Queens
not a professor from Columbia so he does
things like a developer from Queens
meaning it's about respect and
reciprocity servicing a client so you
have you develop a relationship with
your client you make them feel good you
wave the carrot you got the stick but
you wave the carrot the tone at all
times has to reflect win-win it's like
you and I are both going to get
something out of this a lot of people
are critical of this because you're
doing a win-win with a heartless killer
but the fact is he's a developer from
Queens he's dealt with worse the fact is
the options that you have okay you got
to meet with dr. evil but the other
option is you don't
and that means war or starvation you're
going so if you're if you're against
this meeting then you're saying okay
maybe we just starved these people to
death or 25 million people
through through sanctions and whatnot or
do you actually try something new I
think that's why this is a breakthrough
is because you have a developer from
Queens who said why not let's see what
happens let's see what happens and
everybody who is freaking out about that
and might want to just wait and see what
happens I don't understand the criticism
today I'm especially today of all days
where it was all the diplomacy in one
bit Geraldo you have a perspective from
having covered the conflict in Korea
over the years and you said you were
last we there in 1980s a couple times
you know took Jesse's point first you
know you make peace with your enemies
you don't make peace with your friends
I mean you hold your nose and you go in
there and you know plenty of in wartime
there's plenty of you know criminal
allegations to go around but watching
Dana's excellent program at two o'clock
I mean that line really stuck in my head
can you believe we're talking about
ending the Korean War can you believe
we're talking about ending the Korean
War I mean denuclearization and all this
and you know the nuance and all the rest
many people in America have actually
it's been a part of that because I have
been sent there served in Korea have
been at the DMZ I mean there several
generations of Americans have been there
but what if they unite but they don't
you won't you don't know but I'm just
saying you you're saying what a great
thing it is to talk about now you're
saying it's not gonna happen a
unification I'm talking about a peace
treaty between the United States the
United Nations I think slightly it let's
say they bring up let's say they reunify
and don't needy nuclear well I don't I
don't I don't see that happening I I
wear as a historic example of that
happening I think the the centrifugal
forces tend to keep countries separate I
think they will be they will be much
more intimately United I think their
economies might be much more in sync I
think the the system the North Korean
totalitarian dictatorship will loosen up
over the decades as people get
cellphones my goodness as they get the
satellite TV that I think it will have a
modifying effect on the other country
but I mean to me today along with 3.8%
on
employment and record low unemployment
for black people for Hispanics for women
and and this knows about peace a peace
treaty with with Korea I think this is
the best day of the Trump presidency but
it's one of the one of the best for sure
but I think what's really interesting is
the way he was able to try to apply
pressure across all different fronts
also with the Chinese because without
them being involved in this he had to
put some pressure on them like with the
tariffs as well to be able to get them
to come to the table to support it cuz
they support the North Korean you know
regime otherwise they wouldn't have been
motivated it's at Kimberly's point it
really is about the economy in North
Korea they are on their knees it's
starvation nation and Kim laughing last
year made a promise to his people and
said we are gonna bring you out of the
despicable hole you're in I promised
growth I promise better lifestyle and
standard of living and he has not been
able to deliver in fact since he made
that promise with the sanctions things
have gotten worse so he is dying to
bring his country into the 21st century
and he sees a pathway forward with
President Trump and hopefully they can
work out a system where they can slowly
have the sanctions eased off while at
the same time we take a closer look at
how they ramp down the press that they
gotta pack their bags because they're
going to Singapore I'm just gonna say
Nobel Peace Prize no I was gonna say you
could start by you know surplus food as
a gesture of goodwill you deliver a
one-week supply of grain but also we
also have to stop saying they're on
their knees because the whole point of
this is pride and respect and when
you're servicing a client you don't keep
saying well we got him where we want a
mic he walked them to the car it's a
ship it's a subtle shift that a salesman
knows in a real estate salesman knows
you got to get him inside